- We are counting down
to our season two launch.
That's right. Every time.
All right we are counting down
with uplifting moments from the past year.
Recently we were inspired by the works
one of our guests was doing to help pets
who, like humans, are very much
in need during the pandemic.
Here's a bit of that interview.
(air swooshing)
So all those sorts of
animals has inspired you
to start working with
a new charity, right?
Tell me what you're doing.
- Yeah. So there's this charity
called Stay Home and Foster
and you know, they've already
been doing a great job
of trying to get people to foster animals
and with Stay Home and Foster,
we are actually doing
this next phase of it now,
which I'm really excited about,
which is called Fido
Foster or Feline Foster.
And basically we're trying
to create a community
that connects all the
shelters in our country
and be one place that people can go to.
And it's also somewhere that goes beyond
just giving you the dog, you know,
you can go on and say like,
what are the things that we
shouldn't be giving our dogs
and what are the things
we should be giving them?
So, yeah so with Fido and Feline Foster,
we are trying to create
a real strong community,
that will last, you know,
and that is somewhere
that everybody can trust
and go and be able to
help save these animals
and, you know, and add
a little furry friend
to their family.
- All right. Well, now she's
back to update us on her work
with Wag and the Fido Foster organization.
She is helping our
furry friends everywhere
and we love her for it.
And for many reasons,
she's just fun as hell.
Olivia Munn, everybody.
Hello? (laughs)
- What are you, are you
wearing a NASA suit?
- I am wearing a space suit, Olivia,
'cause we're really clever at this show
and we're launching season two.
I came with a helmet
and everything. (laughs)
- I love it.
- I basically high don't
get embarrassed at anything.
So anything anyone asks me to do,
I generally just say yes and
jump right in the deep end.
So I feel like--
- If you had given me a suit,
I would have worn it too.
- I know. I feel like we're
similar in that sense.
- Yeah.
- First I need an update on
your mom's online shopping.
So what's been the latest
purchase she's made you make.
- Well, the latest purchase
was, so back for father's day.
My mom said that my stepfather, Sam
wanted a hammock because
we're in quarantine.
They can't be beyond, they
have a big beautiful yard,
called her gardening around.
And so I said, great,
I'll get you guys two
so you guys can enjoy together.
And then the other day
I thought to ask my mom,
you know, how's the hammock life going?
She's like, "It's really good."
And I said, what about Sam?
How's it going? And he said,
"Oh, I'm not using it" and my mum said,
"Yeah, no, no. I put the other
one into the storage unit"
and I was like, well, why Sam wants one?
She's like, "No, no, one's for me.
And one's for me for later."
So I was like, so then
Sam's, father said get this,
she picked out for him
that was from the children
was really just for her,
which is very not surprising.
- Which is just a lie. That's awesome.
Well, what is the latest
with Fido foster organization
that you're part of?
You were talking about that last time.
- Yeah. Well, it's been
doing really great.
And the thing that we've really been proud
about incorporating is
training for people.
So, you know, I've worked with Wag
and we've done a lot of stuff with Wag
when it comes to like a dog sitting,
boarding, walking your dog,
but then we've added this new thing
to help people train their dogs
and they can do these
one-on-ones with trainers online,
like these 30 minute training sessions,
which is super important because
when we started doing this
Stay Home and Foster at the
beginning of quarantine,
Wag and I helped with
Stay Home and Foster,
and we really wanted people
to be able to, you know,
hopefully adopt these dogs
and we take them into their lives.
And I know having pets and you do as well.
Like the training that they go through,
if you can get any little bit of training
helps make your life and
their life so much better.
So it was something that I always pushed
in the beginning of working with Wag.
And now we've found out
this amazing process,
especially with online
and doing things virtually
that people can sign up
and actually work with a dog trainer.
So we've been doing that and helping that
and offering that to people
which has been really exciting
to see like people learning
how to train their dogs better.
And then, you know, these
dogs like flourishing
and these new families,
it's been really exciting.
- Absolutely.
All right. Well, I love
hanging out with you so much,
Olivia. I think you are so cool.
Thank you for stopping by.
Everybody be sure to check
out Wag for dog training tips
and also go online to find
out how you can help more
with the Fido Foster Organization cause.